خمسه اشهر المضاف على بدر كارثه فيضانات
باكستان ولا يزال قطاع التعليم يمثل هاجسي
لدى السلطات فوق التقديرات مؤسسات المحليه
ودوليه يقدر عدد الطلاب المتضررين بسبب
الفيضانات بنحوي ثلاثه ملايين ونصف مليون
طالب لم يتمكن من يونان منهم من العوده
الى مقاعد الدراسه
لكننا تمكنا من اعاده تاهيل نصفها بعد
مرور اسبوع على كارثه الفيضانات لكن
البقيه تعاني من شح الخدمات واخرى تم نقل
طلابها الى المباني
بين الكلي والجزئي وبعضها لا تزال اثار
مياه الفيضانات التي غمرتها شاهده على حجم
المعاناه
خلال الفيضانات لكنني الان سعيد برفقه
اصدقائي وبمدرستي
حتى مبنى المدرسه تضرر وتم نقلنا الى هذه
الصفوف
تبنتها الادارات التعليميه لمواجهه العجز
في عدد الفصول الدراسيه في بلد يعد من بين
اكثر بلدان العالم تغيب عن مقاعد الدراسه
تمثل الكوارث الطبيعيه
للسرطان بعد ان عوده الانشطه التعليميه في
العديد من المناطق المتضرره واقناع الطلاب
وذويهم بعوده ابنائهم الى مقاعد الدراسه
يعتبر ايجابيا من الاضرار التي لحقت من
مدرستهم الا ان هؤلاء الاطفال يبدون افضل
حالا من كثير من اقرانهم حيث حاله
الفيضانات دون عوده نحو مليون طفل